what was the perception uh once you were
in the u.s for so many years
undercover um
you know you had obviously a
preconceived notion of what the u.s was
from
you know being overseas
was that was it accurate and
how did your perception change once you
were in the u.s for a certain amount of
time
well you probably know half the answer
of course it wasn't accurate uh
i came to the united states knowing
and
exclamation and not knowing what we call
air fingers right
knowing that
the united states was a dangerous enemy
and had to be defeated
uh to
because
the us and nato was in the way of
the master plan
that that was
you know creating
uh
the workers paradise on earth
where there was no exploitation there
was no poverty everybody got along
it's a pipe dream obviously but uh
that's what i believed in at the time
slowly
i got disabused of some of the the
strongest
communist beliefs
when i had my first job a professional
job
at metlife as a computer programmer
we were told in
in the east we were told there were like
three types of companies that were the
worst in the united states
uh it was the military industrial
complex type companies
uh
the wall street investment companies and
insurance companies and i
started working at an insurance company
and
they treated us very well as workers we
were paid well we got free lunch
and we were even like pretty much
promised the total job security
and i was
constantly looking for the evil bosses
you know there were some bosses you
didn't like but there was no there was
no systematic exploitation there was no
systematic uh what you would call
unfairness you know
you
based on your performance you could go
up the ladder and and make a lot more
money so this was all pretty good so
so part of my ideology
melted away rather quickly
um what i was still
still at heart a communist i just
thought
just maybe
there's a way to combine the good parts
of uh capitalism within within
the dream of a communist egalitarian
society and
and get everybody happy uh that was
actually a theory that was uh called
convergence theory it was developed by
social democrat parties in in europe
uh and it was popular for a while and i
i sort of thought that that might be a
way out
anyway um so
we were
misled but here's a here's an
interesting
statement
it is much easier to believe a lie if it
has a kernel of truth
when you know something when you can
relate to something that is true then
everything else that you're being told
that you don't know about you think it's
true too
example
we knew
for a fact
that in west germany there were some
ex-nazis who made it all the way
up to the top in the government
we call them neo-nazis uh
at one point uh the west german
chancellor by the name of court george
keisinger
was had been a member of the nazi party
uh and the head of the uh
the bundesligans which is the equivalent
of the cia
was a fellow by the name of reinhardt
galen
who
under hitler was in charge of uh
espionage on the eastern front
so
we knew that there were nazis in the
west german government we figured you
know that they would eventually come
attack us and uh
uh
and unite germany and
sort of recreate the third reich with
the support of of the united states and
that was the reason
why
given
why east germany built the wall in
1961 and i believed in that too you know
these nazis that were going to come over
and you know
conquer us
so um
and
another lie
we didn't know that there was a kernel
of truth but we clearly didn't know that
it was a lie that uh the fact that the
standard of living in the west was
significantly higher than in the east
was explained to us that you know the
imperialists the evil imperialists were
stealing all the wealth from the third
world countries like natural resources
fruits and vegetables and stuff like
that
i
i had not really shed that belief
because
i had no information to the contrary
so now vice versa
so fundamentally
in uh one more thing here fundamentally
nobody in the east
no high level
communist parties members no no
no
philosophers
no
not not the folks in the kgb really knew
how the united states functioned
didn't know were ignorant because it
clearly they believed in their own lies
and and here's a problem if you want to
deal with an enemy and you don't know
how they how how the system works
uh you are
you know you're missing a joker in your
deck
vice versa
the cia had no clue what was going on in
in in the you know in the ussr
and i'll give you a very interesting
example i met the fellow
who was in charge in the cia
for the east for eastern europe all of
eastern europe so he was a direct report
to william colby
and
he wrote a book and his book is the
the the most
the most
uh telling sentence and
sort of funny that goes as follows i'm
copying i'm
citing from from memory
and so i said in my office he writes i
said in my office and watched the only
credible source of information
about the soviet union
cnn
and this was in the context of uh you
know what happened when the soviet union
fell fell apart nobody nobody knew that
no the same way when the wall came down
uh the cia had no clue what was going to
happen neither did the stasi
nobody
it there was stuff that just happened
and when the soviet union fell apart the
cia was caught by surprise
wow so it was there was a lack of
understanding uh cultural understanding
uh and
an economic understanding
and it had a lot to do with
being lazy and not really trying to get
into it and
believing in your own prejudice
going back to what we're talking about
before you said that during your time
there was maybe a max of 10
yes there were 10 10 uh undercover kgb
agents in the usa i don't know if they
if they made it they were there were 10
that were trained right and sent out it
is quite likely that quite a few of them
had actually had a had to abort when
when i look at the danger points that i
passed
uh there were at least a half a dozen
where could have been caught where i
could have
blown my cover
uh the other guys
were faced with the same problems
it's not easy to show up and say hey
i've always been here right right then i
told you how i
uh how i was so careful
uh with my integration in society so as
to not betray the ignorance that i came
here with
[Laughter]
i